it's a video of a beluga whale in these  kids at an aquarium my mom almost  exclusively shares pictures of dogs and  cats that need adoption children scaring  a favorite song and dancing mid football  fresh hug of bel-air chicken soup recipe  and then we've got a dog book awards who  doesn't love buck award it's a kitty cat  that needs a home and a dog that needs a  home there's a cat that needs a home  that's this is exactly my mom my mom has  cared more about our animals than our  children for as long as I can remember a  very rare video of Helen Keller with  andy sullivan a squirrel got its head  stuck in a Halloween decoration and  terrified the neighborhood that is  terrified my mom's digital presence is  basically her in real life but just the  most effusive sentimental extreme  version of it she literally shared  something every hour and tags me every  time in everything she shares